that new Greek tanning place Santorini
tan is doing a half-off for law
enforcement you get to half off of any
tanning or what they call speed tanning
I have an announcement to make
[Music]
0:06 1418 okay everybody have way their
printed uh thousands of everybody it
happens putting some suckers on my to-do
list though now uh when I had that out
loud it was oh I'm so sorry not
everybody's here because what I want to
say I wanted to say to all EU but bloats
all at once all right mm-hmm
you people have been blisters on my
taint
and not just blisters but ingrown hairs
and yes there's Cabernet in this cup all
right I won the lottery last night you
know why cuz I willed it to happen huh
I'm gonna go out and snort coke off a
black man's behind you didn't hear about
this three six 14 1846 51 yes yeah
they've printed 3,000 of them but um
there is some coke and evidence and
Jones is a pretty good sport nice coat
that real yeah
oh yeah baby
Oh shaaka
yes you want a lotto guess you mother
for the record you're the second person
to come in and tell us to suck your
black who else did
[Music]